OMEGALUL
Hyper Poggers
So, gleich da Text, kein weg, weil ich bin ja gleich da
Den sind Wackbarn
So, erstmal Settings einstellen
Aber irgendwie hat es das jetzt beim Accountwechseln
Komplett
Wieder zurückgesetzt
Was natürlich auch ziemlich räudig ist
Irgendwie, ne?
So, Scope Sensitivity
Hat sich irgendwie auf 05
Mouse Sensitivity hat sich glaube ich auf 9
Brings das Menü, ist übelst von Overwatch kopiert
Das sieht 1 zu 1 so aus
Wie Overwatch das Menü
Also ich meine, das ist ja auch Paladins
Royal, das Werkband
Die haben gedacht, hey, wir haben uns jetzt bei Overwatch hinten dran gehackt
Mit dem Game, also können wir uns auch bei Fortnite
Hinten dran hängen mit dem Game
Und davon abgesehen, dass das
Das einzige Battle Royale Game ist bisher
Was mir Bock macht
Das
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, ehrlich gesagt
Hyper Poggers
Musik
Musik bisschen leiser machen
So, und hier muss ich die Musik ausmachen
Weil sonst sackt das, Alter
Warum hier Fortnite
Weil ich das Bauen in Fortnite nicht mag
Ich weiß, das ist im Prinzip genau das
Was Fortnite ausmacht, aber irgendwie
Irgendwie macht es mir keinen Bock
Lol, Alter
Musik
Ich versuche jetzt mal, das Neamtool zu starten
In der Hoffnung
Ich habe keine doppelten
Ah ne, das geht nicht, da muss ich umstellen
Die Katze will raus
Die Katze will raus, Alter
Ich lasse dich raus, ist gut
Ist gut Katze, ich lasse dich raus
Der Katze ist immer geil
Die Katze stellt sich vor die Tür
Macht sie die Tür auf
Ne, ich gehe jetzt nicht raus
Ich gehe jetzt schrecknup
Hast du keine Katzenklappe
Doch, aber es geht hier um ja
Mein Arbeitszimmer, da habe ich keine Katzenklappe
In der Tür
Die lag hier hinter mir auf dem Sofa
So, ich muss jetzt mal Musik ausmachen
Dass ich was höre, weil das Game
Wow, MonkaS
Das Game ist Soundhorrring Deluxe
Sag ich euch
Jetzt geht jetzt der Sound wieder kaputt
Das passiert in dem Game irgendwie manchmal
Bisschen leise, oder?
Bisschen lauter mache
Ja, muss man nämlich was hören
Sonst hört man nichts
Sensitive
Irgendwie stimmt meine Sense nicht
Was ist da los?
Wie kommst du, dass du das Game spielst?
Ich muss ja irgendwas mal spielen
Es gibt ja irgendwie nichts, was mir gefällt
Und es gibt vor allem kein Battle Royale Game, was mir gefällt
Außer das, das finde ich ganz gut
Wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Ultra Profi
Ich spiele das jetzt ja nicht so lang
Ne, da Fabian spielt das nicht
Der Fabian hat keinen Bock auf so einen Scheiß
Ah, springen wir da mal ab
Da geht, also wenn man hier abspringt
Ist immer das beste
Dann ist man entweder instant down
Oder man schreckt was
Auf, gib Gas
Battle for 5, Battle Royale
Ja, ich kanns ja kaum erwarten
Ich kanns kaum erwarten
Ja, ich sag gleich was zu dem Game
Ich muss mir erstmal kurz einspielen
Siehst du, das war schon übelst eine Fail-Landung
Irgendwie ist keiner hier gelandet
Ich weiß auch nicht warum
Ich muss lauter machen
Leute, sagt mir mal wie der Sound ist
Ich muss glaube ich lauter machen, weil ich höre die Gegner nicht richtig
Schwerter ist der größte Crap in dem Game
Was war denn das da hinten?
Ich hab da hinten was gehört
Moment Leute, ich muss kurz raus terben
Ich muss einen Tick lauter machen, ich höre nichts
MonkaS, hoffentlich verrecke ich nicht
So
Perfekt
Jetzt hör ich was
Und wie sich das natürlich gehört, erstmal bei so Games
Komplett alles ausschalten
Meine Waffen sind übrigens scheiße und hier ist einer
Ich muss gucken, dass ich irgendwie eine gescheite Waffe kriege
Sonst ist instant rip angesagt
Ok, paar Tränke sind nicht verkehrt
Alter, es laggt
Es laggt
Oh, ich höre was
Oh, der hat noch eine beschissene Waffe als ich
Gut, nice
Ok, das sackt
Meine Waffe ist hübelst der Rotz
Da drüben ist noch ein anderer, oh fuck
See you
Ich bin weg hier
Jetzt Sandwichen wir ihn
Schreckt
Alter, sag mal
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ey, es ist Sandwich
Sandwich, Alter
Sandwich, was soll
Alter
Ja, out mich please
Ok, dann nicht
Ich bin weg
Pst, pst
Die sollen sich selbst bewegen
In 8 Minuten werde ich wiederbleiben, in 8 Sekunden
Ja, findet mich nicht Leute, findet mich nicht
Blitz
Nix wie weg
Das war HypermonkaS gerade
Und ich habe
Übelste Rotzwaffen ey
Ich konnte weder was looten noch sonst was
Ich glaube die Runde das wird nichts
Ja
Wonka Giga war das
Das war nicht MonkaS, MonkaMega
Haben die sich jetzt eigentlich gekillt da oben
Oder stellsen die sich
Die stellsen sich immer noch ab
noch einmal
fack fack nicht armor
ich hab keine waffe
ach fack alter
scheiße
ok
ich hab ja nix ey
naja
das hat echt jetzt
wir haben uns so lange rum gedrückt
dass die helfte der leute verreckt ist
ok
hier
guck mal silver noob
so ähm warte mal
ich wollte doch jetzt irgendwas machen was hab ich vergessen
irgendwas hab ich auch gesagt was ich machen muss
ha
weiß nicht
muss ich grad machen oder so
ist
ist die lautstärke eigentlich in ordnung gewesen
in game
hat das gepasst
ich muss halt den
soundtrack von dem game aus machen
lautstärke war gut ok
ich muss halt
den soundtrack von dem game aus machen
das ist
größere soundhoring als
cod 4
das ist
du spielst das game teilweise
nur nach sound
weil ich natürlich sehr praktisch finde
ich mag ja so games
wo man was hört und die gegner ordnen kann
wo man dann quasi um die ecke stehen kann
und dann mit der shotgun peep and bang in your face
ok
ich weiß nicht fortland ist nicht mal ein fall
ich mag fortland
mir gefällt das bau nicht
und popke ist mir zu viel rumliegen
ich bin ja allgemein kein battle royale fan
aber das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice hier
das macht spaß
allerdings neige ich in dem game dazu mich
aufzulegen
aber nachdem das solo queue ist
dreh ich mich da nur über mich selbst auf
das ist dann halb so wild
es kann aber sein dass ich stream klein rage quitte oder so
äh übrigens
armbrust ist dreckes waffe
äh es hängt
normalerweise springen hier
mindestens 5 gegner oder so ab
mal hören
nix da
gut nice
so jetzt haben wir
zumindest ein bisschen
halbwegs brauchbare waffen
ähm das game ist
bisschen anders als die
meisten anderen
battle royale games
die es so gibt
man kann craften
an jeweils
an der schmiede
und um zu craften braucht man material
das sind einmal diese shards die man hier einsammelt
und um seine
um die beste waffe zu craften für die
boah monka ist was hier los
braucht man muss man gegner killen
das heißt wenn man keine gegner killt
kriegt man keine gescheite waffe
was ziemlich sackt
ich hör was
oder nicht, das ist mein eigener gaul
das ist mein eigener gaul
oh nice
besser als
die armbrust auf jedenfall
ja und von aufgehobener
rüstung und so kriegt man
rüstung also sieht man ja unten
ich hör hier was rum ballern
ok die flanken jetzt
flank
flank action
aber vorher holen wir uns nochmal ein paar tränke
hallo
entschaden, desentschaden
ach so flank
jetzt
jetzt werden sie gebashed
oh mage schon was
was hält denn der aus
jaja
wo ist das hähnchen
jetzt können wir was craften
jetzt haben wir genug material
wo ist der typ hin
unten ist er
get wrecked
get shrecked
so und jetzt müssen wir schnell was craften
in der hoffnung hier ist keiner
so erstmal lack waffe craften
armor potion ist immer ganz gut
wow wow wow alter alter
monkaS
monkaGiga
schreckt
fuck fuck fuck ich hör noch was
alter
ich brauch mal eine lack waffe
na fuck
alter
scheisse
feels bad manner
intense
tja
kann ich alles gewinnen
das ich mag halt bei dem game
wie man eben auch gesehen der fluss ist nicht so
das ist nicht so lahm
also man looted nicht erst 3 stunden
und liegt auch nicht 3 stunden rum
und
man looted halt ein bisschen was
best part gegner craften waffe
ihr habt es gerade gesehen ich hab halt den einen treffer gesetzt
mit meinem legendary granat werfer
der andere halt
ich hatte ja vorher schon damage drin
das hat ja gleich mal 800 damage gemacht
hätte ich den nur 1-2 mal getroffen wäre der halt
so ich muss unbedingt mein memetool starten
jetzt müssen wir mal ausprobieren ob das
funktioniert
in fullscreen
ich glaub ja net dass das funktioniert
glaub ich ja net probieren wir mal aus
ne nicht so wirklich ne
aber
ne das klappt net sakt
ok das muss ich da nachfixen
jetzt muss ich da nachfixen
danach ich stelle danach um capture
in window
in window modus
moin
es ist immer schwierig namen ohne
vokal auszusprechen
oh mega lull
ich stelle danach in window modus um
und dann kann ich wenigstens ein bisschen
paar memes
wieder spammen
spammen
oh zu hoch
zu hoch
lagged oh wie das lagged
hat der gesehen wie das lagged
komm her
oh ne kackwaffe
besser
kommt man da hoch mit dem rocket jump
hey nice
zip jump hing
ah sakt
healtoter am beste
meint hier ist einer
da blinkt er weg
wo ist ne andere gewesen
irgendeiner hat mich hier gerade abgeballert
schreckt
aber
wo ist denn der
ich sag gleich
ich erzähl euch gleich was zu den glasen wenn ich
umgestellt hab
ah der hat ne kackwaffe
den onwards
get schreckt
oh mega schreckt
moment schießt der was auf mich gerade
oder bin ich einfach nur
bam alter genau
genau
hyproslee
ach da schießt wirklich was auf mich
fuck
wo war denn der jetzt
da da ich sehs
mal jetzt omega fair trick
als seh ich dich nicht alter
wo ist er denn
immer schön
durch die bäume hüpfen bei sowas
dass diese
diese waffen die sind so ganz merkwürdig
rumgelegge hitscannig
guckt euch das mal an
ganz komisch
jetzt hat er jetzt getroffen
das sind überhaupt kein hitscann
die waffe oder
das ist projektil oder was sagt ihr
ist das projektil
das ist eine projektil waffe oder
hallo
bam
ach das ist kein hitscann
deswegen fühlt sich das so komisch an
ok ich muss
craften gehen leute ich muss um mit dem craften gehen
wir haben viel zu lange hier rumgehampelt
craft reno
müssen wir machen
ich hab genug shards ich hab
ein schickenbein also
meine hähnchen keule
die man braucht zum waffen craften
craften
foggers alter
ich hau mal meinen letzten heal raus
dass ich auf jeden fall
in die schmiede komme
diese projektil waffe das ist ganz merkwürdig
zu aim
ok der will fortune
soldiers of fortune
ne
zu labern
der hat schnipper
weggeschneiber die sau
fuck
das ist anvil 3
auf welcher engine das läuft
anvil 3
kacke
weggeschneibert
halle mich
genau
ich wollt hier umstellen auf
window capture
nehmen wir das mal
yes
remove yes
zack
window cap
nein man visual studio will ich nicht aufnehmen
fuck
moment achso
ich muss ja erstmal wieder das ding umstellen
in borderless window
so und nu
jetzt
ne
he
kann man das nicht ordentlich capturen oder was
was ist das hier
warum kann man das nicht capturen
window capture
he
ok
ok das game
kann man nicht capturen
das ist auch ganz toll
window capture geht nicht ja da müssen wir wieder umstellen
und game capture machen
da kann ich
aber keine memes einblenden
tja
ja da müssen wir mit leben
so game capture
so jetzt gehts oder
seht ihr was
ja das ist doch
wie kann man das game nur fullscreen capturen
sehr komisch sehr sehr
komisch
na gut ich könnte
ich könnte Bildschirm capturen machen
ich mach danach einfach Bildschirm capturen
gut ist
ok
ich finde wenn man hier
landet ist eben wie man sieht
das ist am Anfang die übelste Action dafür
wenn du da raus kommst hast du super gear
du hast deine lag waffe
ordentlich hast du ordentlich armor
ah fullscreen
seht ihr was? ja ne?
das muss jetzt funktionieren
ja also als klassen gibt es hier einmal
das was ich spiele engineer
da kannst du torbmäßig
türmchen bauen
oder barrier setzen
oder rocket jumpen
das ist
relativ close quarter lastig
defensiv, dann hast du warrior
das ist quasi close quarter lastig offensiv
da kriegst du als legendary weapon
statt granatwerfer kriegst du
so ne wurfachst die alles
owned
oh oh oh
ich brauche unbedingt
bevor ich jetzt mit dem trite
hol ich mir mal auf jeden fall
ein bisschen tränke
ah nice
ey da
ey da ey da ey da ey da
ey da ey da ey da ey da ey da
f
Oh, weggekockt.
Ah, hier war noch was, oder?
Battle Royale Games mit Bugs, ja, das hätte ich selbst nicht verwirklich gehalten, ne.
Meine Fähigkeiten fehlen übrigens.
Wow!
Das war close.
Alter, der Typ fuckt mich ab.
Ops, hätte ich vielleicht aufheben sollen.
Hast du die Fußballspiele gesehen?
Nein.
Hab ich nix geguckt von.
Gar nix fußballmäßiges geguckt, wie im R-O-Mega-Lol.
Ich hab meine Fähigkeiten nicht aufgehoben, wie der letzte Kackknob.
Ich brauch unbedingt Heiltränke, ohne Heiltränke ist jetzt RIP angesagt.
Kommen Videos zur E3, ne, die E3 ist noch fertig.
Koggers.
E3 ist noch fertig.
Ich hab doch zu jeder Pressekonferenz einen Streben gemacht.
Oh nice.
Oh, die Dinger, die Pistolen sind so schlecht.
Die Pistolen sind so schlecht.
Oh, die sind so kacke.
Ich brauch, ich brauch Heal.
Ich brauch Heal, vielleicht gibt's hier noch was.
Problem ist ja, ohne, ohne, ohne Heilt kann ich jetzt hier schlecht rein.
Ist schon offen, ne?
Fuck.
Hier hinten ist auch schon auf, oh ne, das ist jetzt, das ist, das ist RIP, ich seh
schon was kommt.
Ich glaub hier war ich noch nie drin, hier ist auch alles offen.
Alles Crap.
Okay, wir awnen den Typ jetzt an der Schmiede.
Wir awnen den Typ einfach an der Schmiede jetzt, easy.
Easy.
Oh Mann, das war, als ich zu wenig Leben hatte.
Oh Mann! Das war, als ich zu wenig Leben hatte. Scheiße!
Fuck!
Ach, was ein Scheiße, ey.
Ah, weggekockt.
Reverse weggekockt.
Ähm, vielleicht noch ein Meinungsvideo zu E3.
Ich glaube, da kann ich nicht allzu viel sagen, weil meine Meinung zur diesjährigen E3 war, das war stinklangweilig.
Das stinklangweilig. Also, Nintendo war für mich die Enttäuschung pur.
Leute, wollen wir uns, komm, wir gucken uns abschließen, wollen wir uns doch mal den Smash-Stream angucken?
Wollen wir uns doch mal, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal 20 Minuten Smash an.
Ich meine, er hätten so eine Smash-Direct machen können, aber ich habe bei Nintendo darauf gewartet, dass sie mal was zum Online-Modus zeigen, zum Beispiel.
Also, irgendwas, was man noch nicht weiß. Ich meine, das einzige, was man zum Online-Modus weiß, ist, dass er irgendwann, wann startet, im September?
Dass er wahrscheinlich was kostet und dass es irgendwie NES Classics oder irgendwie so ein Mist gibt.
Aber ich meine, ganz ehrlich, NES Classics, wer braucht denn NES Classics?
Guck mal, im Zweifelsverlass hat es jetzt irgendwie schon vier oder fünf Mal gekauft, ein NES-Spiel.
Da hast du ganz theoretisch gekauft, auch wenn er es ist.
Dann hast du es irgendwie wie Virtual Console oder sowas gekauft.
Dann hast du es irgendwie wie U-Virtual Console gekauft, falls es, nee, das war was Eigenes, ne?
Dann hast du es irgendwie jetzt demnächst dann noch im Online-Mode.
Das ist doch bescheuert in meinen NES-Games, ja?
Jaja, es gab einen Nintendo Stream.
Au, au. Hier.
Der.
Ich wegbashen neben mir.
Aber kriegt er nicht hin, weil ich ihm die Waffen wegcrabbe.
Fuck.
Fuck, verpiss dich, Alter, verpiss dich.
Achtung, Achtung, jebaited, jebaited.
Fuck.
Alter, was soll ich denn da machen?
Was soll ich denn da, was genau hätte ich da jetzt machen sollen?
Ich hätte wegreiten können, wahrscheinlich.
Fuck.
Ich hab gedacht, vielleicht ist er so doof und springt mir irgendwie nach und ich kann mit dem Schwert wegschwerten.
Pushen, ich kann mit dem Engineer nicht gescheit pushen, weil ich keine Run-Speed hab.
Der ist schneller wie mich, schneller wie ich.
Also das Hunter, der läuft zwar nicht schneller, als das, der läuft schneller als ich, aber ein Hunter, da kann er ja wegrollen.
Also ich hab eigentlich keine Chance.
Das Einzige, was ich machen könnte, ist versuchen, von oben irgendwie mit dem Rocket Jump draufzuspringen, aber wenn er nicht ganz so bescheuert ist, dann wreckt er mich.
Aber das war jetzt auch sehr unglücklich, dass da keine Waffe drin war in der ersten Kiste und dass ich übelst gesandwiched wurde von beiden Seiten.
Sackt.
Die Map ist unprägens übelst unfertig, wie man hier sieht, ne?
Hast du mal Passive X eingespielt? Ja, hab ich mit Fabian gespielt. 200 Stunden oder so, als das noch Beta war.
Ah, bestes, bestes Spot.
Wenn es so weiter geht, steig ich, steig ich irgendwann wieder ab in Bronze oder so.
Bronze Noob.
Platschat, äh, Platschat.
Oh, jetzt wird, jetzt wird weggecrapped. Wieder Mastercraft, jetzt wird weggecrapped und alles geowned.
Was, was war das denn? War das kein Hit oder was? Wollte ich verarschen?
Wollte ich rollen oder was?
So, wo ist der Typ jetzt hin? Wie jung bist du eigentlich? Ich bin 33.
Wo ist der Typ hin?
Ok, da gibts Tränkel. Tränkel beste, wichtigste.
Keine Fähigkeiten am Start, keine Rüstung gescheit, ok.
Bisschen was, immerhin. Wir gehen jetzt mal anders rum. Wir gehen jetzt nicht links hoch, wir gehen jetzt rechts rum.
Die haben sich bestimmt schon alle verpisst.
Hast du nie nur Kuni 2 gespielt? Nee.
Im ersten Teil fand ich geil, im zweiten Teil fände ich wahrscheinlich auch gut. Hab ich auch nicht gespielt.
Oh nice, nice.
Auch sehr nice, sehr schön.
Ah, jetzt läufts.
Geowned.
Das ist das richtige Skyrim Pferd hier, guck.
Kannste auch 90 Grad Bände hoch reiten.
Ok, wo ist denn hier was?
Einfach schonmal die Hälfte der Leute Toten, ich hab noch nicht alle Gegner richtig gesehen.
Hier ist bestimmt alles gelootet drinnen. Wow, da ist einer.
Ok.
One.
Der ist da drinnen.
Alter, was? Wo ist hier was? Bin ich dumm?
Korgas.
Die sind nicht hitscann Waffen, das ist ganz grausam.
Ok, wir müssen uns verpasst verpissen.
Die U-Aim.
Wow.
Wo ist der Typ? Ah, da hinten.
Ich seh dich. Push a Reno machen wir jetzt, Achtung.
Der hat nur Armbrust, Korgas Armbrust.
Wo ist der Typ?
Wo ist der Typ? Oh, das war krass. In your face, Alter.
Wo ist denn das Hähnchen hin? Also hier war ja noch ein Hähnchen.
Da muss ich mich jetzt beeilen, das muss ich erwischen.
Oh fuck, Korgas. Der Typ lebt schon wieder, der andere.
Wow.
Was? Oh, Alter.
Ich muss mich pissen. Und jetzt gehen wir da hoch und wenden sie.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich muss den Abstand halten, ich glaub der hat seine Leckwaffe.
Was? Oh fuck, was ist hier los? Ich muss meine Waffe holen, shit.
Die hat bestimmt schon jemand gelotet jetzt. Nee? Nice.
Da geht doch was, oder? Da hat doch was geplitzt.
Wo ist der Hunter? Hunt Wars? Verpiss dich.
Der flankt den jetzt und dann werden sie immer beide wegfisten, ich sag's euch.
Oder nicht.
Oh shit, shit, shit.
Fuck, ich bin ein Kackno. Scheiße, ich bin so dumm, ich bin so dumm.
Warum bin ich denn nicht so dumm? Oh, wie dumm.
Ja, ich bin so dumm.
Naja, sehr, rank up, es geht aufwärts. Ja, Blockwater, es ist Battlefield 5.
Also ich finde die Frage allein schon übersichtlich.
Ich finde die Frage allein schon überflüssig. Siehst du das nicht? Ich zeig dir das gleich mal, guck mal.
Ich zeig dir das gleich mal, woran man das erkennt. Hier gibt es nämlich Armprothesen.
Was war das jetzt?
Ja, ich mag das Pacing von dem Game irgendwie, das ist permanent geht was.
Von Anfang an.
Wie gesagt, Spieler nicht, sondern nicht lang.
Ich glaube in dem Game kannst du übelst ownen, wenn du, wenn man ein bisschen eingespielt hat.
Halt die Schritte, halt die Schritte, das geht übelst ab.
Hier.
Das Gear erinnert mich an WoW, ja das ist ja auch, also Paladins war ja schon, ich weiß die Paladins-Fans wollen das nicht hören, weil man sagt, das war eine WoW-Kopie.
Eine Overwatch-Kopie, sagen wir mal, das war sehr inspiriert von Overwatch.
Und nachdem das hier ja im Endeffekt Paladins Battle Royale ist, ist das halt auch sehr inspiriert von so ziemlich allem, was es sonst so gibt.
Korgas.
Was?
Die hat nicht einmal geschlagen.
Okay, das war jetzt irgendein...
Was?
Okay.
Was war das denn jetzt?
Ich dachte mir, okay, wenn die nichts macht und auf mich zuhört, dann switchen wir halt zum Schwert.
Ja, reckt.
Na gut, der Hersteller kann sich jetzt damit rausreden und sagen, das ist ja Alpha.
Das ist ja Alpha, da ist das ja alles kein Ding.
Aber das ist einfach ein historisch authentischer War Simulator.
Da sah das nämlich so aus.
Wahrscheinlich hat es einfach nur geleckt, ja.
Ich weiß aber nicht, warum es lecken sollte, ehrlich gesagt, aber heute sind die sauber eh.
Also an meiner Hinterhaltverbindung liegt es garantiert nicht.
Ähm, übrigens, ich habe gelebt.
Ich habe gelebt.
Ähm, übrigens, ich habe gelesen auf Reddit, dass man, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich heute Encoding Option habe, ja ich habe heute Encoding Option.
Ähm, ich habe gelesen auf, auf dem Twitch Subreddit.
Dass man auf Twitch jetzt bis zu 8 Mbit streamen kann.
Das muss ich dann mal ausprobieren die Tage.
Weil 8 Mbit würde schon, wäre ein Riesensprung von maximal 6 Mbit.
Das wäre ein Riesensprung, das würde einfach viel besser aussehen.
Oh nee.
Omega Lull.
Ich muss weg.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ups.
Das war ziemlich dumm, jetzt.
Kommt man hier hoch?
Wobei, das habe ich schon ausprobiert, nachdem man hier hoch kommt.
Man kommt hoch.
Aber es ist schon gelootet.
Achtung.
Da ficken wir jetzt rein.
Ähm.
Darf ich mal fragen, wo genau geht hier was?
Ich habe so eine räudige Pistole, äh.
Ah, da hinten geht was.
So eine richtig räudige Pistole.
Die Pistolen sind in dem Game das schlechteste, was es gibt.
Gefolgt von diesen komischen Revolvern.
Die sind auch übelst kacke.
Oh, das sind Tränke.
Ich brauche Tränke, Leute.
Ich brauche Tränke.
Unmöglich Tränke.
Wow.
Wurde ich gerade gehostet?
Ich kann gerade nicht.
Ich gucke, ich gucke klar nach.
Ich habe nur den, ich habe nur den Hosting Sound gehört.
Danke, danke schon mal für den Host.
Ich sehe es gerade nicht.
Poggers, Alter.
Poggers.
Hier war einer.
Je nachdem, wie huge der Host ist, muss ich jetzt nervös sein.
76.
Oh krass.
Ich höre da was.
Ja.
Mal austauschen.
Kacke Pistole da.
Oh nice.
Da haben wir Salvation in den Krämpel.
So und jetzt, jetzt schleichen wir uns.
Jetzt müssen wir noch was.
Ne, wir haben schon einen gekillt.
Ok, wunderbar.
Äh, schleichen wir uns mal zur Schmiede.
Gucken, was da so abgeht.
Ja, war da, war da links?
Da ist einer.
Wow, was ist hier los?
Gehen wir mal hier hoch und hauen mal kurz ab, dann können wir ein paar Tränke abgreifen.
Okay, ich sehe jetzt gerade nicht so genau durch ehrlich gesagt. Was hier? Oh, oh, oh, da unten.
Was ist denn hier los ey? What the fuck? Okay, das mit Craft wird nichts.
Und ich hab noch nicht mal ordentlich Rüstung. Oh, das ist räudig.
Headshot. Direkt. Oh, fuck. Oh, ich bin schüß, da hätte er mich nicht erwischen können.
Puh, jetzt kann ich mal nachgucken, wer hat mich eigentlich gehorstet hier?
Highscore heroes hat mich gehorstet. Poggers, Poggers, das war anstrengend ey, da muss man sich so viel konzentrieren bei so was.
Ich muss da sagen, ich hab jetzt mittlerweile, also ich hab am Anfang mal PUBG ausprobiert, ich hab dann mal ganz kurz Fortnite ausprobiert.
Fortnite ging mir übelst auf den Keks, weil man bauen muss. Spielt einer von euch Fortnite und also, ich meine das Bauen ist ja so das was Fortnite hervorhebt, so gegenüber anderen Games.
Was ich jetzt allerdings auch gelesen hab in der Fortnite Community ist das so ein bisschen umstritten, ne?
Also viele die Fortnite spielen sagen auch, ich hab auf das Bauen kein Bock. Wie ist das denn bei euch, bei den Fortnite, bei denen die Fortnite spielen?
Also ich hab bei vielen Leuten schon gelesen, sondern an sich finden sie Fortnite schon nicht schlecht, aber das Bauen nervt.
Ich meine es kann halt auch nicht jeder in 5 Sekunden hier wieder Turm hochziehen oder sowas.
Ja und Popke war mir ehrlich gesagt zu lahm und zu viel rumgeliege.
Ich habe das ja sogar damals gekauft, dass ich ein bisschen mit dem Air spielen kann, aber das war irgendwie langweilig.
Warum spielst du kein Overwatch mehr? Oh das ist eine lange, das, da weiß ich ob ich das fast jetzt aufmachen soll, ich hab's ja schon oft gesagt.
Also das Hauptproblem was ich mit Overwatch eigentlich hab ist, dass das Rank zu wenig mit dem eigentlichen Spiel zu tun hat wie es gedacht ist.
Oh oh hier wirds aber, oh oh hier wirds voll. The fuck. Oh piss dich alter.
Ok Achtung Hopp. So da werden wir jetzt mal was wegficken hier. Was ist denn hier? Ok keine Ahnung. Ist das hier eine Decoy oder sowas ne?
Ok wir verdrücken uns mal kurz und holen mal ein paar Tränke. Man spielt sogar Paladins gar nicht. Oh ich brauche Heal, Helz brauche ich Helz.
Wo war ich gerade bei Overwatch? Also wie gesagt das Hauptproblem ist einfach, dass das so wenig mit dem zu tun hat wie es eigentlich gedacht ist. Wahrscheinlich war mein größtes Problem, dass ich das am Anfang ja mit einem festen Team gespielt hab und wenn man eingespielt ist und man muss Rank spielen, das ist einfach so ein wahnsinniger Unterschied, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Moment haben wir das nicht schon? Und dazu kommt auch eine weitere Sache, die mich nervt ist, dass die Patches sind das alles irgendwie nur im Schnellen.
Lag? Jetzt weiß ich ja warum das gerade alles nicht richtig reingeht, weil es laggt wie Sau. Dass alle möglichen Patches und Balance Änderungen und hast du nicht gesehen, dass es in Overwatch im Schneckentempo passiert.
Ich brauche eine Rüstung. Ordentliche Rüstung. Nicht nur Rüstungs Tränke, sondern ordentliche Rüstung.
Okay, jetzt ist beides Kacke. Oh, über mir gehts. Geht die Party ab, ja.
Direkt. Der lebt noch, der andere, oder?
Okay, holen wir mal erstmal das Chicken. Wo ist es? Wo ist das Chicken? Chicken!
Okay. Ja, ich verschwende mal meinen einzigen Heal, weil ich muss den Scheiß irgendwie überleben.
Und jetzt müssen wir zur Schmiede unbedingt. Wir haben genug Shards, wir haben unseren Hähnchenchenkel, aber der Mage hüpft hier halt noch rum.
Wir looten jetzt hier nachher und dann gehen wir direkt zur Schmiede, weil es wird ja langsam mal Zeit. 13 Sekunden noch bis die Foggers insettet.
Ah, das ist der Foggers. Wonka Foggers. Nee, nix. Okay, flanken wir mal rüber und gucken.
Ja, das war so nicht gedacht. Wonka Giga. Okay, ist Forged. Ist Forged. Gehen wir mal rechts rum, wir flanken jetzt. Flanken jetzt mal rechts rum. Und bashen die.
Wobei uns fehlt so ziemlich alles, ne? Uns fehlen die Waffen, uns fehlt alles.
Hat er seinen Schneiber?
Fuck, der hat seinen Schneiber aufgehoben, ne?
Siehste?
Scheiße. Wir waren zu langsam an der Schmiede. Ich glaube die beste Variante wäre gewesen, der einfach zu einer anderen gegangen wäre.
Der hatte genug Material und alles. Und wenn der seine Leckwaffe looted, bringt es eigentlich überhaupt nichts, wenn ich da irgendwie großartig Action mache mit dem.
Ja, ich lese gerade im Chat, dass irgendwie Overwatch-Balancing, ich habe, ich verfolge, also ich gucke ja noch viel Overwatch League.
Und in der Overwatch League ist es ja wirklich gerade gar nicht so wild. Also ich meine, es wird zwar nicht jeder Held gespielt, aber es ist ein bisschen mehr Vielfalt als im Ranked. Zumindest einmal so Master Plus Ranked.
Aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie macht Overwatch keinen Bock gerade.
Wenn das alles ein bisschen schneller gehen würde, dann vielleicht. Ich glaube das einzige, was du machen kannst, wirklich um Overwatch ordentlich zu balancen, ist eben es nicht zu balancen, sondern um neue Helden rauszuhauen.
Also mit nicht balancen meine ich halt, man sollte nicht, man sollte quasi nicht Patches releasen für Balancing, also nur für Balancing oder es daran ausrichten,
sondern einfach sagen, wir machen mehr Helden und machen Balancing ein bisschen so links und rechts. Dadurch, dass es mehr Helden gibt, hast du halt auch viel mehr Variationen drin und dann musst du den Kram nicht so viel balancen.
Da hast du halt viel mehr Optionen und viel mehr Varianten, wie du spielen kannst.
Aber das ist denen wahrscheinlich ziemlich wurscht, will ich das erzählen.
Sagen wir mal, kann das sein, dass wir die letzten drei roten Neubels abgekackt sind?
Lustigerweise war aber permanent was los.
Ich kann übrigens nicht so lange. Ich muss gleich noch meinen Clary leveln.
Abends 18 Uhr spielen wir wieder Dungeons and Dragons.
Aber nicht on stream, ne?
Mein Clary ist jetzt Level 4 und ich kann jetzt auswählen, ob ich welche, welche Stats ich erhöhen will mit Level 4.
Und falls sich da jemand von euch auskennt, sag mir mal, welchen, welchen Stats soll ich denn erhöhen?
Also ich hab natürlich alles, alles auf, alles auf Weisheit, ich mein ich bin ja Clary, ne?
Und Weisheit, Kon, Stärke.
Was lohnt sich denn jetzt davon am meisten, über so einen Schwellenwert zu bringen?
Was so, ne? D&D Profis.
Also ne, also quasi über 15, über 17 und sowas, was soll ich da?
Wahrscheinlich Weisheit als Clary, oder?
Und für alle anderen, die keinen Platz im Chamber haben, voll nicht kreditorisch, weil ich kann euch das jetzt auch nicht besser erklären.
An die Shotgun hätt ich nehmen können.
Nice, so. Okay, Flank Action, Flankerino.
Nicht hängen bleiben.
Die Kiste, habt ihr gesehen, wie die Kiste reingeleckt hat?
Wow, hinter mir.
Ich will jetzt den Typ aber noch wegkocken.
Oh, der hält ganz schön was aus.
Der will sich jetzt heal sonnen, ich sag's euch.
Was?
Nee, der ist abgehauen.
Lol.
NA Aim.
Mega NA Aim.
Wir 4 flanken jetzt außen rum und dann werden wir von der Seite reinwäschen.
Ich muss zur Schmiede, unbedingt. Schmiede Reno.
NA Aim.
Oh, KS.
Da hielt sich auch der Typ.
Oh, da ist ein lila Spell, das brauch ich.
Korgas.
Wo ist er denn?
Alter.
Okay, ich muss craften Leute, ich muss unbedingt craften.
Scheiß egal, ob ich hier was übersehen hab, ich muss unbedingt craften.
Hm, das kriegen wir fertig, das kriegen wir fertig, bis der Fog am Start ist.
Bis der Fogger's.
Ah, no.
Fuck, ich hab nicht genug.
Ich hätte mehr Looterino machen müssen.
Ich loot jetzt, scheiß drauf.
Das war dumm, ich dachte ich hab viel mehr.
Ich weiß ja, dass hier hinten noch Zeug liegt.
Ich hab alles looten müssen.
Was ein Slang, ja, so ist es.
So, wenn wir schnell sind, können wir noch craften.
Korgas braucht eine Minute 40, bis er da ist und die Waffe braucht glaube ich eine Minute.
Und ich denke mal, hier ist keiner, weil das so direkt am Rand der Map liegt.
Fuck.
So, das wird ganz knapp, das wird ultra knapp.
Wenn ich das Ding nicht krieg, ey, beißt mir in Arsch.
Ich meine, es sollte passen, es sollte passen.
Da war was, oder?
Fickt sich.
Der muss jetzt kommen, der Typ.
Fickt dich.
Oh, wat?
Korgas, Korgas.
Korgas, Korgas, Korgas.
Alter, fick dich, Scheiße.
Zu wenig Tränke, ich brauch mehr Tränke, ich muss auch noch mehr Tränke craften.
Mit mehr Helz wär der gefickt gewesen.
War bestimmt Streamsniper, das lag nicht an mir.
Muss, muss Streamsniper, kann, muss.
Oh, es geht aufwärts, wir sind jetzt schon silbernoob.
Ja, Sam Fisher, das kommt manchmal vor, also manchmal überlebt man das als Chicken.
Also, ich glaub, am Anfang vom Stream haben wir es auch mal kurz überlebt, als sich da
zwei Gegner gebashed haben gegenseitig.
Aber das Game macht übel Bock, also endlich mal ein Battle Royale Game, was ich gerne
spiele.
Ich hab das ja mehr oder weniger erst, keine Ahnung, drei, vier Stunden oder irgendwie,
nee, oder, nee, ein bisschen länger schon.
Weiß nicht, ich hab's letztes Wochenende mal ein paar Stunden gespielt und heute, aber
ich bin ja selbst noch ganz neu in dem Game.
Es hat Hacker, ernsthaft, hab ich, ich bin noch keiner aufgefallen bis jetzt.
Was denn, was denn für, wie kommst du da drauf, dass es viele Hacker hat?
Und was für Hacks, also so die klassische Wallhack-Geschichte, Aim oder irgendwie Minimap
oder so.
Okay, haben wir es schon.
Brauch mal.
Also ich hab jetzt noch wenig gesehen, also an irgendwie Cheater, aber wie gesagt, ich
spiel auch noch nicht lang.
Wollen wir uns hier unten noch mal was, aus, das laggt übelst, ey, was ist denn heute
mit den Servern los?
Ihr seht es ja teilweise auch, dass man sich so rumwarpt.
Das Rumwarpen ist das Schlimmste.
Und was auch merkwürdig ist, dass irgendwie glaube ich, also der Unterschied zu letztes
Wochenende, wo ich es auch schon mal angespielt hab, ich hab den Eindruck, die haben manche
Waffen von Hitscan, von Hitscan zu Projektil geändert.
Kommt mir so vor.
Was ist hier los, da hab ich übrigens noch kein Gegner gekillt, dafür müssen wir was
killen.
Da ist einer, oh was.
Wo ist er?
Da ist von rechts gegen den Mage angeflogen gekommen.
Der wartet doch jetzt da drin, der will mich schnetzeln oder sowas.
Ich hab da von hinten was gehört.
Sag mal, gibt es da irgendwie die Möglichkeit, um drauf zu kommen?
Oh, die battlen sich, da ficken wir jetzt rein.
Ich hab's schicken vergessen, ich brauch's schicken.
Scheiß drauf, wir gehen zur Schmiede.
Schmiede ist keiner dran.
Wir haben nicht genug, wir haben nicht genug für Waffe, wir müssen noch was bashen.
Achtung, der wird jetzt geownt.
EU-Aim, EU-Aim-Twitter jetzt, hau da ab.
Hä, sag mal, wie der hier noch hergesprungen ist, wollen die mich rollen, was ist das hier?
Der ist irgendwie so wupp wupp wupp wupp, was ist das?
Wir können nix craften, wir haben zu wenig, aber diesmal hab ich nicht zu wenig, Pots.
Wir brauchen die Waffe, das ist eigentlich das wichtigste.
Das wichtigste ist eigentlich die Lackwaffe, damit kannst du auch Gegner killen, die besser
ausgerüstet sind und dann kriegst du auch das bessere Gear.
Aber immerhin, wenn ich überlege, wie übel ich gesagt hab am Anfang, so als Battle-Royale-Noob,
wie zumindest ein bisschen weniger ich jetzt noch sage, ist da schonmal was.
Wo geht denn hier was?
Oh, nice, Legendary-Kiste, da kommen jetzt 20 Gegner hin.
Sehr nice, entschreckt.
Reiten wir mal zur anderen Schmiede.
Jetzt fehlen jetzt halt noch 90, ne wieviel braucht man, 70, irgendwie, craftmaterial.
360 for the win, nur so geht das, also ohne, ohne ist nicht möglich.
Ich kann ja meine Lackwaffe nicht craften, Gegner, keine Gegner da, aber wir gucken mal,
ob da Kisten drin sind, weil wir haben immer noch kein richtiges Gear, kein ordentliches.
Hier waren auf jeden Fall Kisten drin.
Reiten wir mal zur Kiste, mein, irgendwo müssen ja mal Gegner sein.
Der Vorgast kommt.
Ja, Totem ist richtig nice, das stimmt, Totem ist übelst nice, Heal Totem, was irgendwie
nicht umsonst so, ich finde das sieht aus wie ein WoW-Schaman, Totem irgendwie, Gegner,
gibt's nicht, overrated, jebaited, keine Gegner, ich höre auch nichts, also es ballert
auch keiner rum.
Gegner, nix da, keine Gegner, ich meine das einzige gute was wir haben ist eine gute Waffe,
restliches Gear ist Müll, wir können auch nix craften, wow, der wird jetzt geohnt, wat?
Oh nee, ich hab den Helm gesalvage, nicht nur, wobei eigentlich ist es bescheuert, ich
salvage den Scheiß lieber, geh in die Schmiede und mach mir mal noch was Gescheites, Moment,
wo ist denn die Schmiede hier, sind die nicht hier, ah nee, da drüben, oh oh, da kommt
noch was, ach scheiße, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, fuck, wie kann man es eigentlich so
sehr verkacken ey, ich hab sogar noch den Schatten von dem Typ gesehen ey, ah, dumm
ey, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, ich ragequit jetzt, cu.